driving into at-at a village which is
inside the exclusion zone created by the
Fukushima nuclear disaster you don't
really immediately notice anything out
of the ordinary I mean you see houses
and shops and everything you would
expect to see in a Japanese village and
there aren't any clues that this has
been the site of the worst nuclear
disaster in twenty-five years or so the
only way you really know is when you
look at your Geiger counter and here the
one I was using shows a reading that's
about roughly ten times the natural
background depending on where you are in
the world this is not enough to make you
sick right away but this is definitely
enough that you wouldn't want to be
living in this area anymore which is why
it's been evacuated by the Japanese
government when you get out of the car
you really start to feel that there's a
difference here things are very quiet
the curtains are drawn in all the houses
and one of the first things we saw was
this dog she had been left by her owners
because her owners couldn't take her to
an evacuation center and so they did
what a lot of people in the Atatu
village have done they chained her up
and they leave food and water for her
and come back a couple times every every
week to refill the food and water and
basically she's left to her own devices
the longer you're in the exclusion zone
the more you really start to notice
these subtle differences you see rice
paddies that have been completely
overgrown you see farm buildings that
are empty all the livestock was
slaughtered at the time of the accident
basically out of fear of radioactive
contamination and you do see some other
signs of human activity this is the only
piece of graffiti I saw in my entire
trip to Japan the first symbols there
are for TEPCO the Tokyo Electric Power
Company which was responsible for the
meltdown and you see security personnel
protecting the even more dangerous
exclusion zone beyond it today so we
drove right up to the gate the furthest
week ago and that was still about 30
kilometers from the plant there's a
plume of radiation that came to the
northwest and that's why a Tata had to
be evacuated the other people you would
see inside the exclusion zones were
cleanup crews and you would see these
these groups of people scraping away the
top few inches of soil to remove the
contamination because in fact the
contamination doesn't go very deep into
the earth they were sort of little by
little clearing away the the topsoil and
putting it into these bags that were
then piling up all over the prefecture
and it's still not clear where all these
bags of contaminated soil are going to
go after visiting the Tata village the
next day we drove to new raha town which
is a town inside the exclusion zone to
the south of the plant and directly on
the Seacoast and what we saw there was
very different people hadn't been able
to clean up the tsunami damage so in
other parts of Japan and coastal Japan I
visited you would barely even know a
tsunami had happened but here there were
still ruined cars and houses the flood
plain was completely washed out roads
had been washed out and hadn't been
repaired and I guess to me this is
really what the nuclear disaster at
Fukushima is all about is that this this
cleanup hasn't happened people haven't
been able to move on with their lives
you